well what's amazing is I think the last
time we talked we had like a couple
million users on Instagram it's been a
little over five years it's been like
getting there it's breakneck speed we've
built from a company of 13 people now to
just shy of about 500 and it's crazy the
scale I mean we have nearly 1 out of 3
people in the United States using
Instagram every single month as well
it's ubiquitous and that's every
entrepreneurs dream you added the last
100 million users faster than the 100
million users before that why do you
think that is I think it's a couple
things one images are a universal
language I think they speak to everyone
so it allows us to grow globally very
very quickly
the second is we're here at Facebook and
if there's any company to kind of learn
from how you grow very quickly
internationally Facebook has been a
tremendous help with our infrastructure
and expertise so I think that's helped
as well globally where do you see large
pockets of users which countries or
cities are incredibly popular yeah I
think like Brazil is one of the biggest
countries and you see that as a very
different type of culture especially
technically they use different phones
different platforms etc but are they're
totally into social media and they love
sharing their lives through images
that's a great example because my
co-founder is actually from Brazil and
when he goes home he's like he's in
all-stars I realize Mike's from Brazil
he's from Brazil originally yes so what
are your plans to harness that during
the Olympics during the Olympics well
the Olympics every single time it comes
about is a big moment on Instagram
you've got all the athletes you've got
all the interests in the different
countries represented and now that
Instagram is so big and is so global I
think it's a great platform to go tune
in and see what's happening on the
ground we're preparing for a brexit vote
what a brexit impact your business would
that impact Instagram I mean it might
tangentially but as we've seen we have a
thriving community in the UK obviously
those folks in the UK are connected with
everyone into you as well I don't think
it'll be a big deal for Instagram tech
companies have complained about the
challenges of working in Europe and with
European regulators for a variety of
reasons what's been your experience
working yeah when we were talking
earlier I expressed how much my job has
changed I didn't realize how can play
you know it would get to run a company
of just 13 people with you know 30
million something users around the world
to know over 500 million taking each
country on its own with local laws local
regulations and understanding them we
want to be globally available so we're
working really hard on that we have a
big team that focuses on that as well
it's been one of the most interesting
learnings as a CEO as we've grown